Speaker 1: So Trump had a
rally in Iowa over the weekend.
We looked at the things that Trump himself said,
and it was completely out of this world bonkers.
Trump still getting support from Iowa
Republicans. Chuck Grassley was there.
So were others. What about the people that
go to the rally? Because without them,
Trump is just a guy speaking into a microphone?
Really, really great stuff. From Ron Phillip Koski
cataloging and covering the rally goers. So let's
just go through some of these and you're going
to see really again, what we're up against
here is Jane Jane says she decided to move
from Alaska to Iowa when she heard Trump
would be there. This is crazy. Take a listen.
Speaker 4: I found out about the rally before
I moved, so that was part of the incentive
for moving as well. It's my first rally.
Speaker 2: President Trump made someone
move to Iowa to go to one of his rallies.
Speaker 1: By the way, this young lady wearing a
socialism sucks hat. There's no socialism in the
United States, but socialism sucks. Is her hat
Speaker 2: right? What excites you
the most about President Trump?
Speaker 4: Oh my gosh. Everything he tells
everything straight up. It is no lies, no B.S.
nothing. And that's what this country needs.
Speaker 2: Absolutely no political
correctness and all thing. No lies.
Speaker 1: Get what? How do you? I mean, how?
How this? This is the most dishonest president
we've ever seen. And part of what appeals to
her is Trump tells it like it is and he doesn't
like. She also moved because Trump did a rally.
I considered moving actually to Louisiana. Once,
when Billy Joel played, I heard Billy Joel was
playing a concert there and was like, I should
really move there. That that makes sense. OK,
here's another woman who explains that
her family hates Trump and she breaks down
crying. This is really something to see face.
Speaker 2: I know my whole family has turned
liberal and I don't know what happened
because I didn't raise them that way.
And they've all been brainwashed to think that
he's the most horrible man ever when he's saving
everyone, right? I mean, I'm going to start
getting emotional because everything depends
on this. America depends on this. We have got
to save. We've got to do everything we can.
And I'm not even an American citizen. I was
born in England, but I've been here since that.
Speaker 1: I don't know why I find that extra
funny after the crying. I'm not even an American
citizen now, but she lives here, OK?
Speaker 2: I mean, this is my home
and we've got to save it. We just got to got it.
Speaker 1: But that may have huge damage. She
doesn't even vote, which is interesting.
Speaker 2: I, the God wins in the end.
Right? That's why the enemies are
lashing out right now. We know,
we know we're going to suffer for a while, but
it's going to be good. It's going to be more
glorious than anything we've ever seen.
Speaker 1: And you understand, I mean, the guy
introduces the the full religious thing. But then
she she talks about this idea. If we're going to
suffer in the short run, it's
Speaker 2: all
Speaker 1: this kind of Christian
dominionism extreme ideology.
Speaker 2: I do have faith in God and pray
and do everything we can. Everything. Yeah,
absolutely. We will. We will. I mean, just keep
the faith. That's why I have complete faith that
this man is going to save us. He's going to end
basically saving the world, not just us, everyone,
everyone. And I just can't wait until I'm never
going to say I told you so, but I'm just going
to be just so happy and I don't know what else
to say. My husband was the United States Marine,
and he died from Agent Orange from his
time in Vietnam. And I'm alone little.
Speaker 1: So I mean, that's, you know,
at least her family figured out that they
shouldn't support Trump. That's that's good. It
shows us that even within families, some people
can ultimately see reason. That's good. Here's
another woman who explains that during Obama,
Christians were persecuted. But then Trump
came in, and then they had freedom of religion.
And Trump is like the most Christian president
ever, which is just so not factually accurate.
Speaker 2: Is it that you support President
Trump so much? Oh, it's it's it's just it's
just heartbreaking what's going on in our
Unidentified: country right now. When President
Trump, OK, when we're when we were in a bad man,
Speaker 2: you know, like some Christians,
we've been persecuted a lot.
Speaker 1: OK, that's not true.
Speaker 2: And then when we. Trump came.
Speaker 1: All right, you're back,
you know, there were no rights that were
reestablished for Christians under Trump
Speaker 2: and freedom of
Speaker 1: religion. You always
had it. It's in the Constitution
Speaker 2: thing in a week, you're
free. You know, President Trump is the most
Christian. So Christian was pro Israel.
Speaker 1: Trump may actually be an atheist.
It's actually shocking how non-religious
Trump has bamboozled so many people
into thinking he's a Christian
Speaker 2: pro-life, you know,
and all that pro-life,
Speaker 1: he claims.
At six eight, he he became pro-life.
Speaker 2: All his policies are amazing,
you know, like, he really has just kind of became
pickier, you know, out into love this country. So,
yeah, so we we were really, you know,
glad for him. We're grateful for him
and know what's going on with the communism.
Speaker 1: All the mandate. There's no communism,
Speaker 2: you know, we're like being strangled.
You know that our freedom is being stolen from
us. So it's really, you know, and now, of
Speaker 1: course, this is like a perfect
example. If you actually ask her, give an
example of a freedom you've lost in the last
nine months under Joe Biden. You would get an
interesting conversation if you said, give us
an example of communism in the United States, it
would get very interesting. The real question is,
is this just a low IQ individual or is this a
brainwashed individual? Or is it both in some way?
Here's one last one just to show you the crazies.
Some guy said he was there to deliver legal
documents to Trump to help. I don't know what
the documents are supposed to do. Let's see.
Speaker 2: It's Thomas. OK, rich, go ahead. Oh
yeah, our says you are the 46th president period,
says our Lord. Dear Mr. President Donald
J. Trump, I have come to deliver legal
documents to you so that you can give them
to your legal team. Period. Our king Jesus
Christ has spoken to put you back in your
office at the White House. Now that's funny.
Speaker 1: Are they legal documents or are they
religious documents? If it's Jesus who has spoken
to put Trump back in the White House? Why is it
even a question of legality? Like isn't? Isn't
Jesus more powerful than legality?
Speaker 2: Sincerely rich Thomas
words. I had the legal documents. Oh, I'm here
to put President Trump back in office now.
When he does watch us so right? Mr. Trump, let me
up. I have two documents. I'm here at the rally.
I'm waiting to deliver. King Jesus
says there's time to deliver. Are
you hearing me? Absolutely. There's a real.
Speaker 1: OK, so king Jesus there says it
is time to deliver. I don't know what we make
of this. What I do know is it's really hard to
reorient these people to reality, whether it's
hard because of just limited cognitive capacity,
whether it's hard because of brainwashing,
whether it's, you know, I'm not saying it's
mental illness, but whether it's some kind
of emotional imbalance. It's very tough to
fix what we just saw. Let me know your thoughts.
We'll take a quick break and be back after this.